Speaker 1: Hey, you might be excited to learn
Kari Lake, who lost her race to be the Arizona
governor. She now has a lawsuit. She
has a lawsuit. Ladies and gentlemen,
she appeared on the Steve Bannon Real America's
Voice War Room program. I still don't even know
what that is. But listen to this insanity.
A friend of mine texted me two days ago.
He said he lives in Arizona, said I was in Arizona
at my local car mechanic place, getting my car
tuned up. And in the waiting room they had Steve
Bannon's show on. Oh, mind blown. I have never
heard of such a thing. Okay. Steve Bannon's
show, Trump attorney Christina Bobb is there.
And Kerry Lake is there. And Kerry Lake
declares they are ready to go with a lawsuit.
Now, what is the lawsuit going to do? I have
no idea. The election in Arizona was certified
yesterday. Kerry Lake lost. Katie Hobbs will be
the governor. But folks, they have a lawsuit. Is
this a grift? Let's see if we can figure it out.
Speaker 2: How possibly can a Republican attorney
general sit there and a governor sit there and
allow this fiasco? People in Arizona have to
understand some independents and Democrats.
You look like idiots on the world stage. This
looks like something that would happen in
the worst. A banana republics. Kerry Lake.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Before she answers, one of the
worst things that could happen is a candidate who
didn't win, ending up in office. And fortunately,
that's not going to happen because this lawsuit's
not going to go anywhere. But let's listen to it.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I mean, the optics in just
a little over an hour, the optics of them
sitting there and signing their signature.
Can you imagine? To this sham election? They
did it back in 20, 22 years ago. And many of
us gasped and said, How could they do this? Why
couldn't they give more time to look into all of
the issues? Now fast forward 20 and remember.
Speaker 1: There's never been enough time. The
audit wasn't done correctly. The recount wasn't
appropriate. There was barbecue sauce on the
ballots. And they still counted, you know.
Speaker 2: To today. And we've got more
issues than we saw in 2020 in that sham
election. We have just a blatant sabotaging
of Election Day, a disrespected, disregarded
disenfranchisement of Election Day voters.
Speaker 1: None of this is true.
Speaker 2: And if they sit there and sign
their names to this sham certification. History
will never forgive them. They will go down as as
three of the very worst in history. Yeah.
Speaker 1: It was signed. Katie Hobbs is
officially the Arizona governor elect and
she will be Carrie Lake's governor very soon.
Speaker 2: Now that we know and by the
way, we're at the top of the first thing
and getting to the bottom of the FBI,
the DOJ and I think CIA involvement,
intelligence apparatus and law enforcement.
Speaker 1: Steve Bannon thinks now that the
CIA is also involved, these people's brains
are filled with mayonnaise. And, by the way,
pretty bad mayonnaise. I would say.
Speaker 2: It's an apparatus involvement
in the coup d'etat in the 2020 election,
because remember, ladies and gentlemen,
they all knew we had the receipts. This
something you have to understand. We were
wiretapped. They read our emails, all of it.
They knew we had the goods. They knew this is
not just about a corrupt and incompetent media.
It's about this in 2020. How does the Illinois.
Speaker 1: Now remember and Bannon almost just
jumping around frenetically between topics the
entire they wiretapped us. They spied on us.
Understand what happened? It's really simple. What
happened. The Trump campaign was in touch in 2016
with so many suspected criminals who themselves
were being surveilled by law enforcement
that the people on the Trump side of the
conversations were, incidentally, are surveilled
in that way. It's sort of like if I right now,
as part of doing my show, regularly
spoke to, say, organized crime people,
the organized crime people are under
surveillance. Would it be accurate for
me to say the FBI is spying on me? No. What's
happening is I'm talking to so many suspects
of the organized crime investigation.
My side of the conversation is getting
picked up by the FBI. That's what happened.
Speaker 2: Ask the release of this. What's
happening on President Trump's 2020 tied directly
to what's going on in 2022 in Arizona, ma'am.
Well, I mean, to watch what happened over
the weekend. I think what what Musk put out,
the information he put out. I think it was a
game changer. And to watch the silence on the
part of the mainstream media, no silence.
Speaker 1: It's just there's not much of
a story there. It was revenge porn. And the
Biden campaign, which was not the government
at the time, tried to have it removed. So,
listen, Katie Hobbs will be the governor of
Arizona. That's the good news. If Carrie Lake
continues living in Arizona, Katie Hobbs will
be Carrie Lake's governor, period. That's the
story. They had the audacity yesterday. Yes.
To certify an election for Katie Hobbs that
Katie Hobbs won. That's good news. Carrie Lake
didn't win. If Carrie Lake somehow ended up
governor. That would be a very bad thing. And
it's disturbing that we have to explain this to
people. The person who got more votes should be
the governor. It would be bad for democracy
if the loser still got to be governor. It
would be a version. Of the participation trophies
that these very same people claim to be against.